[Music]
[Music]
on saturday
january 13 2018 at exactly 8 07 am
an emergency alert appeared on every
phone across hawaii
ballistic missile threat inbound to
hawaii seek immediate shelter
this is not a drill people ran
desperately for cover
hid their children and sent last
messages to loved ones
those who had found shelter had to
anxiously wait for the bright flash
and intense blast for an atomic bomb but
nothing
38 tense minutes passed and a second
message was finally sent to everyone's
phones
there is no missile threat or danger to
the state of hawaii
repeat false alarm
shaken and confused people emerged from
their impromptu shelters
and quickly wondered what exactly had
just happened
it all turned out to be a terrible and
avoidable error
culminating in a simple misclick of a
button
before the incident itself the people of
hawaii already had legitimate reason to
believe that a nuclear strike might be a
reality
in 2017 the year before tensions between
the united states and north korea had
reached an all-time high
kim jong-un's isolated nation had been
performing more and more weapons tests
and even launched a missile that passed
over northern japan
but most worryingly they also had been
successfully designating a series of
nuclear bombs
which demonstrated to the world that
north korea's nuclear weapons capability
was developing
at a faster rate than anyone initially
thought
at this point north korea was believed
to be able to produce missiles capable
of reaching hawaii
if you're unlucky enough to be caught
directly beneath an atomic bomb
you can expect or perhaps unexpect to be
vaporized
instantly leaving behind in every shadow
of carbon where you once stood
those further out and not in cover would
simply ignite
along with everything else in the
vicinity those who are cocooned from the
blast
have potentially a worse fate to deal
with severe burns and radioactive
poisoning from the fallout
which if in contact with the skin can
cause internal bleeding
vomiting cancer and death
we know this from eyewitness accounts of
those caught in hiroshima
on august 6th 1945 and those caught
three days later in nagasaki on august
9th
what survivors saw in the immediate
aftermath of those atomic strikes
are too horrific to share in this video
so i've linked to a book below that i've
been reading lately to mark the 75th
anniversary of those devastating attacks
that i believe to have killed an upward
estimate of 226
000 people
[Music]
so to have to wait for an imminent
nuclear strike like those in hawaii that
day would have been stressful to say the
least
after the incident a reddit user began a
thread asking people what they did in
those 38 minutes
i started off trying to wake my
roommates up to no avail then
in extreme denial i walked outside my
home to see if anyone else was
hysterically preparing for a disaster
there were crowds of people running to
their cars from the beach the freeway
was completely blocked
and yet there were also elderly people
who didn't get a notification
just watering their lawn as if nothing
was happening after the five minutes
outside which felt like an hour i walked
back to see my roommates awake
switching through channels and seeing a
banner on every channel that warned us
to seek shelter
stay on the floor and away from windows
then
i received a frantic call from my mum
from california
in tears saying how much she loved me
i'm calling my dad and two sisters
saying it could be the last time they
might talk to me
my sister 12 felt so rushed and said
that she loved me but didn't know what
else to say
i could hear my other sister six saying
how could ryan be dying there's no way
at this point my biggest fear was no
longer dying it was the thought of my
family i'm leaving behind
i told them how i live in an area with
low population and away from military
bases
and i should be fine with my water and
food reserves
mid-cool i receive an upcoming call for
my uncle who lives on the island
i figured he had important news that was
relevant so i told my family i had to
hang up
he told me it was a false alarm i
proceeded to tell everyone else
and that concluded my most stressful 30
minutes ever
roughly 10 minutes after initial alert
representative tulsi gabbard tweeted
that it was a false alarm
soon other public figures and groups
started to spread the news via twitter
but took a total of 38 minutes for
everyone to receive a text
clarified that no nuclear strike would
take place that day
an investigation into the incident
concluded that it was a combination of
human error
and inadequate safeguards that
contributed to the transmission of this
false alert
it was the result of a drill that had
started with some regularity last
november
around the time hawaii reinstated its
cold war era nuclear warning sirens amid
growing fears of attack by north korea
during the drill the midnight shift
supervisor played a recording over the
phone
that included the typical drill language
but also erroneously contained the text
warning that a live ballistic missile
was incoming
the recording does not follow the script
contained in the standard operating
procedure for this type of drill
around 8 05 am an employee initiated the
internal test
from a drop down menu on the computer
program he saw two options
test missile alert and missile alert
he was supposed to choose the former he
erroneously chose the latter
an initiation of a real-life missile
alert
the employee who was responsible had
been working for the emergency
management agency for 10 years
but had allegedly confused real-life
events and drills
at least two times before he was
initially assigned to another position
but was eventually fired from his job
since the incident
the unnamed employee who made the
mistake has received most of the blame
and sadly numerous death threats have
forced him to live in anonymity
despite having publicly expressed his
deepest apologies
[Music]
the 2018 false missile alert over hawaii
has got to be one of the worst false
alarms in recent times
and despite the shock and panic that
occurred that day things would turn to
normal pretty quickly afterwards
for the time being 75 years have passed
without nuclear attack
let's aim to keep it that way
hey thanks for watching links are as
always down in the description below
it's been great to see some new faces to
the channel and i really appreciate so
much positive feedback to my content
so if you're new consider subscribing to
the channel
i aim to get a video out every friday
until then
goodbye